the best boxing buff story happened to
Brian Urlacher the greatest one we
created this games that was called box
him up because everybody got like Nike
and Reebok shoes and different things in
clothes and then you'd have the boxes a
couple boxes left over some people will
be walking and if they're not paying
attention you just run up behind him and
slam the box over the head right and say
box him up so everybody had to have
their head on the swivel locker room so
Brian was really good at getting other
people to cuz he's sneaky yeah like you
get you coming out of your meeting room
or so and boom you got a box slammed
over your head he would get so many
people that yeah everybody kind of had
it out for you everybody turned on here
was the box bully yeah you don't it took
me once you get boxed on once I'm like
you're getting ahead of me like
literally around the locker room you got
your back to the wall yeah I'm keeping
everybody in front of I think the d-line
brainstorms on like will be the best way
to try to get them enemies its boobs
brilliant I'm imagining the deal I'm
doing like a space shuttle launch yeah
they probably had like protractors and
all kind of stuff you know these are
electric so you've gotta get yes right I
don't know how they got this box wheels
like a six foot box in an our locker
room there's stairs to go to the second
floor while the cardio stuff is and
there's a platform so you can't see
who's up there so he comes out and so
right when he walks out from under the
platform somebody drops that six foot
box right on his head yeah his arms down
it dropped like straight over me like
I'm stuck in the box
hey everybody I box him up all you saw
was two little feet like kicking out a
little box